jackal maintenant dominique bush
donnez l'écoulement soir vous êtes
journaliste auteur d'ouvragés
d'investigation dans quels documents
biographie et vous publié aux éditions
numéro un un livre qui savait didier
deschamps vainqueurs dans l'âme qui est
consacrée au capitaine des bleus segment
fait
donc bah oui dit deschamps capitaine de
l'équipe de france et gagner le mondial
que gagner l'euro 2000 évidemment
pourquoi lui pourquoi pas je pose si
dany les plus de l'amour que lui non
barthez maison parce que zidane avait
déjà écrit sa biographie
j'allais peut en écrire un deuxième lui
parce que je trouvais que c'était il
avait l'image d'un anti héros d'une anti
star c'était quelqu'un d'assez
énigmatique et je me suis dit c'est un
joueur qui a le plus gros palmarès du
football français qui a été capitaine de
l'équipe de france pendant dix ans qui a
été capital de toutes les formations
dans lesquels il a joué
et pourtant quand on le voit comme cas
c'est vrai qu'il paye pas de mine mais
je me suis dit je sais si c'est vrai en
même temps mais bon il est pas très poli
les patrouilles footballeur au péage de
l'autoroute on fait attention à lui il
m'a fait bulls enfin quelques-uns quand
même il en a marqué quatre dans sa
carrière juste elle sera en buteur voilà
et je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qui se
cache un tueur ou quoi lantieri qui
mangent bien les gâteaux je trouverai un
bon mangeur de guerre
bon
mais quand vous êtes avec moi au début
n'était pas du tout d'accord c'est
quelqu'un de très discret être comment
ça s'est passé mais je l'appelais un
jour j'ai réussi à voir son numéro de
portable par sa maman que je remercierai
jamais assez et je l'aï appelé je
connaissais pas du tout j'ai dit allô
bonjour didier deschamps je m'appelle
dominique roux je suis journalier
j'écris un livre sur vous et la grand
blanc et il m'a dit je ne suis pas
d'accord j'ai l'habitude de tout
maîtriser dans la vie je ne veux pas
écrire de lille je ne participe prépare
et je sais pas pourquoi je me suis
acharné je me suis obstinée jusqu'à
obtenir un rendez vous avec lui où il
m'a dit non et puis par la force alors
il est arrivé encore un peu les cheveux
gras non gelée convaincus qu'ils
méritaient un livre je me suis acharné
j'utilisais n'importe quel prétexte pour
l'appeler et puis après je me suis
adressée à sa mère et puis après sa
femme mais toute la famille dans une
meule encerclé en fait une stratégie
d'encerclement et je l'appelais pour ne
rien lui dire je trouvais les prétextes
et au fil du temps il a fini par se
dérider et à accepter le bouquin mais
j'ai ramené un jeu s'est passé comment
vous êtes souvent comment ça se passe
jamais voulais pas me parler ah ben non
alors que ce que j'ai fait j'ai
interviewé ses parents j'ai interviewé
sa femme et j'ai interviewé les joueurs
l'équipe de france où les gens qui
avaient jalonné sa carrière et temps en
temps au téléphone ait daigné me donner
comme ça quelques confidences à bord ça
se voit pas au célibat vachement c'est
arrivé très bien informé a mais j'ai
aussi un rêve j'ai passé du temps
travaillé jour et nuit